president Trump's tax reform plan was
unveiled by Treasury secretary Steve
minuchin and National Economic Council
director Gary Cohn he is a registered
Democrat and the former president and
chief operating officer of goldman sachs
good morning good morning thanks for
having me do you have the votes for
health care do we have the votes for
health care I think we do this is going
to be a great week we're going to get
health care down to the floor of the
house we're convinced we've got the
votes and we're going to keep moving on
with our agenda as you said we just
rolled out our tax plan last week we're
very excited about our tax fund as well
so we're going to continue to drive
presidents Trump with the judges and
forward look you rolled it out with one
page I mean when will we see the details
and the remaining other so you'll have
some sense of between cuts and where the
revenue might be increased so Charlie as
you said we did roll it out with one
page and we roll out one page versus for
a specific reason we want to get
enormous amount of input before we draft
the final bill when we deliver the final
bill we are going to have a bill that is
bought into by the House and the Senate
you've just been talking about how
difficult it is to get things through
Congress we understand how difficult it
is to get things through Congress you
were talking about how it's designed to
be difficult we understand that we're
going to make this tax bill work and the
way to make the tax bill work is to work
with Congress before we draft the bill
and that's exactly what we're going to
do right now there seems to be a lot of
conversation about how it's very helpful
to the wealthy but what about the
middle-class Gary this is a middle class
tax bill absent middle and lower class
tax bill that's exactly what's designed
I really am confused why people don't
understand what we're doing here if you
look at what we've done we've doubled
the personal exemption in this bill
we've taken the personal exemption for a
family of two to $24,000 the median
income in the United States stays
somewhere between 56 and $56,000 you
take the $24,000 away from the $56,000
you've got taxable income of $32,000
they're 10% rate that's $3,000 of tax if
you have one or two or three children
and we give you $1,000 tax credit you
could end up with a very marginal
single-digit tax rate to no taxes
whatsoever that to me is a middle income
cut because you're going to owe no taxes
potential but you're also eliminating
the estate tax we are but we're also
eliminating deductions we're limiting
the deductions that were added to the
tax legislation over years to favor the
wealthy the wealthy have deductions
middle-income people
and lower-income people don't have
deductions wealthy people have
deductions so we're going to make
wealthier people pay taxes on a much
broader swath of their income will it be
revenue neutral or are you comfortable
adding to the deficit in the short term
in order to increase as I said we're
working with the house we're working
with the Senate we had a great meeting
with the leadership last week we are
going to go through the tax plan its
entirety we don't know what it's going
to score yet because we're going to work
on very specific details we're going to
eliminate as many of the deductions as
we can we think we're going to get them
all out if we get them all out I'm
pretty positive this is going to score
quite favorable you believe you can make
it up by simply eliminating deductions
the giant fall difference between the
tax cuts and what you need to make up
with them you can do that with
deductions we can broaden the base
significantly so we're going to tax a
lot more revenue and a lot more income
but we're going to tax it at a lower
rate instead of taxing at a high rate
but subtracting a lot to get to the
taxable income we're going to tax a much
bigger number at a smaller rate yes we
believe we can make that work what's it
like for you Gary Cohen all right what's
a nice registered Democrat boy doing
working in a Republican administration
work for goal attacked yeah who worked
for Goldman Sachs I'm working here to
drive the president's agenda to make
America better for all America I know
that but what's it like for you
personally are you enjoying this job
that we hear reports about warring
factions within the White House it's
Game of Thrones its house of cards
it's them versus us really tell us what
it's like for you look I came from a
very team-oriented environment the White
House is no different we're a team
oriented environment the president has
put together a phenomenal team of
advisers the president likes lots of
different opinions which is the exact
way I have worked my entire life I've
used to work in an organization where
people are allowed
and encouraged to express their opinions
and express their views so disagreement
is good disagreements good this White
House is no different the president
wants to hear everyone's opinion he
wants to hear both the pros and cons of
every decision and he encourages that
and I'm very comfortable in that
situation first of all we're pleased to
be in the White House hearing there's
much to talk about so thank you for
coming thank you for me to have you at
the White House yeah to highly
appreciate you getting up so early we
will talking this not early getting up
this early the long time